as soon as we
are only having virtual sex and we're
making our babies in tubes and
everything else which is not far away
um
are we really human
if if death goes away Ray Kurzweil told
me years ago 2006.
um he said Glenn you just have to stay
alive till 2030 and I said
okay and at the time I was doing the
math how old will I be and uh I said why
and he said end of death by 2030.
excuse me Ray what end of death I said
we're gonna
cure all disease what do you mean by
that and he said oh no we'll just
download you we'll be able to take you
and download you into a machine and so
there won't you won't ever die you'll
still be able to be called up as a
virtual person and I said virtual person
that's not life Ray that that's that's a
pattern that's not life
robotic slavery right there once that
gets in the wrong hands oh my gosh oh my
gosh
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder of Blaze TV host of The
Glenn Beck program and author of the
brand new book dark future uncovering
the great resets terrifying next phase
my old friend Glenn Beck welcome back to
the Reuben report
how weird is that that I'm your old
friend seriously I am old and I'm your
friend so I don't know if you meant it
as my old friend or
somebody I've known for a long time but
I'll take it either way my old
ideological opponent who became my
friend who's also older than me Glenn
Beck
thank you I need specifics Dave I I live
in a world of specifics you know that
Glenn it is good to see you we have not
done anything on camera for I don't know
probably about a half a year or so so I
want to catch up on a bunch of stuff but
you as if the title of the book dark
future isn't terminatory enough scary
enough Etc you said to me right before
we started since we are holding this for
just a little bit because people know
I'm off the grid right now you said to
me what if I'm dead by the time we post
this video it's an odd way to start a
show Glenn
well I didn't start the show that way I
said that off the air you started the
show again let's be specific about
things
Dave this could be the biggest show ever
if I die before it goes on it would be
huge in fact let me know the week that
it's on and I'll fake I'll just
disappear I'll just disappear and I'd be
around for like two weeks and you can
say you know what's weird about him
disappearing is he might be dead he
predicted it on my show yeah not that
not that you need any help selling books
because because how many books is this
for you and your books I mean like
flattery aside like every book you sell
seems to sell more than the other and
you've done the all the lists and all
the stuff uh how many books have you
written at this point
19 20 maybe I don't even know
I don't even know how do you do it like
how do you with everything else you're
doing just like technically how do you
do it like find the time to do it and
churn through it and everything so I am
I'm going to be real honest with you
because I don't like you know I don't
want to lie to anybody I've not even
read this I have no idea what it's about
it could be gibberish no
um I have a really good team uh that
helped me write and research and what I
usually do is I I'll put all the bones
together and say this is what it needs
to be about uh and then they'll start
putting the meat and then we just shape
it at the end
um and I write it that way I write it
with a team they were really not happy
about this book because I'm kind of a
novice futurist I've been reading you
know Ray Kurzweil and others since the
1990s and uh and they they aren't and
they were like wait we have no knives
like gotta get cracking on the books uh
and so did a lot of research in the
what's nice is
not over anyone's head
um you know it was it was important to
me that we hit Technology Square in the
face but most people think of Technology
still a bit as science fiction and it's
it's science fact
right now science fact
we are we are in the midst of of a
technological Revolution and you know
many people we can do all the Sci-Fi
references people basically would say
you know Skynet is on the machines have
sort of taken over already the amount of
people that will see this very video it
really is beholden to algorithms and
machine learning and God knows what else
uh but before we dive into all of that
you for a long time I give you a lot of
credit my friend you've been right about
a lot of things way before and and I
told you when we first met well before
we had never worked together anything
else I would watch you on I think first
on CNBC and then on Fox you'd have the
chalkboard and I'd be like I can't tell
if this guy's completely insane
absolutely hilarious a genius a lunatic
like all of that stuff but it turns out
you're true
yeah exactly exactly that's what your
next book that's what my book about you
will be on uh but but in essence though
with all of the the Blackboard stuff and
pointing to okay here are the people
doing this and this is what's going on
here you've pretty much been right
within within like a certain set of
limits you've been pretty much right
about most of the stuff
I'm really wrong on timing
um that's where I really get it wrong
um however it's not hard to figure it
out it's really not
um I I will tell you anything that I got
right uh I think
comes more from God than me anything
that I got wrong is definitely
um but uh
you have to just take people
at their word and the first time that I
was really right about something kind of
profoundly scary was September 11th and
I it was uh August of 99 maybe and I was
on the air at WABC and
uh it had to be earlier than that
because Clinton was still in office and
uh and he had just bombed the aspirin
Factory if you remember that and what he
was doing he was targeting Osama Bin
Laden I couldn't even pronounce his name
I'd never even heard of it Osama being
being Laden I think I called him and uh
I said uh look I'm no fan of Clinton
but
this guy is scary this this is one thing
that maybe we should pay attention to
and I got so much pushback from the
audience and I said guys
he's saying he's going to kill us
take him at his word okay you're wrong
if he if he doesn't but at least you're
prepared in case he does and I said uh
within 10 years There Will Be Blood
bodies and buildings in this city and it
will have his name on it if you don't
pay attention to him you just have to
take people at their word
yeah and geez Well you certainly turned
out right on that one and and you've
been ballparking a lot of the other
stuff that is we're going through right
now your last book on the great reset uh
really what's happening everywhere in
terms of this giant globalist government
that seems to perhaps control both
parties right now but certainly control
the Democrat Party and everything else
so is that is that a good place to start
as we enter this dark future just sort
of what's going on politically here at
the moment without getting into just
what happened today or yesterday
in case you're dead by the time we post
this and I don't want it
you know and then I I would say you know
something like that whole Kamala Harris
taking office thing was a surprise and
then it didn't happen yeah anyway
um the um
I think the problem Dave is or where we
should start is
the normalcy bias
um
the normalcy bias gets humans into
trouble it also saves our lives on day
to day on day to day you need you need
um
you know we we are we are we have
trained ourselves to look for dangers
and if we were looking for dangers we
would find them all the time and we'd be
freaking out all the time so we have
What's called the normalcy bias that
kind of fits into the normal pattern so
I got it and so you don't even really
think of that threat
um you know in your frontal cortex so
on September 11th is a great example
what happened there was a lot of the
people that could have gotten out were
making their way down the stairs out of
one of the towers and then they turned
around and went back up because they had
to turn off their computer they had to
they forgot their purse or whatever they
just assumed they were coming back
um because
it was too big to handle an airplane
going through their building they it
just it didn't compute so the normalcy
bias to keep you calm happens
that's what's happening in our world
today people are just pretending and I
think it's natural that all of this is
normal and it will it's still within the
normal parameters and so I don't
nothing's really going to happen and
that is we are right now in the stairs
of the twin towers and it's coming down
you just have to prepare and be aware of
it otherwise it's chaos and panic you
know it's so it's so interesting to me
that you're framing it that way because
you know I'm very proud to say that when
when covet happened I was very early on
on being skeptical like once the the 15
day thing hit when they said 15 days to
stop the the spread on day 16 I was
basically done and the reason I was done
is because of a word that you just said
everywhere every news organization every
commercial every uh Public Service
Announcement kept saying the new normal
it's the new normal and I was like wait
a minute wait a minute you guys just
told us 15 days we'll be good to go and
then overnight The New Normal so so that
has something I think to do with another
word you mentioned earlier about timing
that these things sort of happen in a
way
where we don't realize how much we're
giving away as we're giving it away
because we are geared to Safety in the
herd and that's why the individuals the
Preppers and everybody else the people
who have already made a move to a safer
area or one with a stronger Community
sense they're the ones that are going to
survive I mean Dave I think I asked you
at one point
maybe a couple years ago
at what point do we realize or at what
point do we become the German Jew
that just kept saying it's not going to
get worse than this uh I mean it may not
get worse than this I pray to God it
doesn't get worse to this but we are
we're traveling the same road I mean if
you look at the Weimar Republic
the Weimar Republic went through this
exact same thing it it had its September
11th it had the second world war all the
churches were like we're righteous we're
gonna win don't worry it dragged on
humiliated bankrupt the country then the
younger group the older group didn't
recognize their country anymore and a
younger generation came in and a lot of
the power flipped from the older
generation to the 20 and 30 year olds
then they got rich because during
hyperinflation they weren't married and
didn't have to run out to the store they
could invest it so they got rich
and then
like crazy promiscuity I mean it became
Babylon Berlin became Babylon and most
people don't know that in 1925 the first
trans surgery happened in Germany wow
yeah uh he had several surgeries from 29
from 25 to 29 he died when the final
surgery put a uterus in him
um but the scary thing is Dave on both
sides and I wanna I really want to spend
a little time making sure it's very
clear on this
the first books to be burned were the
lgbtq books that were being put in
schools
pedophilia had started up and all of the
stuff that we're experiencing right now
where there was just a a disengagement
from reality and right and wrong
uh and so by 29 and 30 the churches
which were dead inside they were just
righteous but not christ-like at all
um they they were starting to ring the
bells the Nazis came in the first book
burnings were from that literature the
first people in the concentration camp
were were generally gays anyone who was
said that they were trans any of that
stuff they were the first
this should be a very big warning to
both sides one anyone who says you're a
Nazi for being against these you're book
burning I honestly don't think they know
history but I do and that should wake
all of us up if we don't know history we
will repeat it so they have a reason to
say hey Nazi you know back off we have
to be very careful do you think it's
baked in that we repeat it no matter
what that this is just what the Human
Experience is and that we cannot to some
degree as as a society we cannot Escape
these mistakes that we seem to make over
and over and over again because of the
slow motion nature of some of this
I don't think it's inevitable but it
sure seems
uh very very likely I mean I remember
reading I remember reading the Bible you
first read the Bible and you're like
okay and they destroyed themselves then
you read three more pages and it's a new
society and you're like wait a minute
you're doing the same thing these kids
are just doing right and you're like
hello I mean it wasn't that long ago
look at this is it this is how it
happens
um and we're living it
um I don't think it's inevitable I think
we can change it I think
you know people are just more likely to
go along with the flow
until it's just unbearable and at that
point you know I I I'm doing an art
Workshop up at my Ranch and I've got
these great artists from all over the
world some if I were walking with some
of these guys in India
people would stop us uh but we have
these great artists and we're painting
and painting things that we want to do
but push us beyond our limits and
I I want to tell the story of Raul
Wallenberg I won't tell it's a long
story but
um it's we've discussed it on the show
before we'll link to the previous
discussion on raulberg yeah
um but he's fantastic and I'm inspired
by this this painting of this woman and
man and she's all in her mink and
everything and he's in a top hat and
tales and you can see behind them all of
the theater postings they were going out
to the theater and then a cop coming
down the stairs and it's shot on a shot
of them and the two faces she is just
really like freaking and he looks like I
can't believe this is happening and the
name of the painting is
Friedrich
closed
do you know what that means
and I think a lot of people are going to
kind of come to that point who wait wait
because we're already going down that
way
I'm a terrorist first speaking out at my
school board
do you know what that means
so as okay so I think some people are
waking up to it certainly your audience
is is hearing this stuff my audience we
we talk about this and you know clearly
there's been some pushback a guy like
Glenn youngin one in Virginia because he
stood up against you know stood up for
the parents and things things of that
nature but let's connect this a little
bit to some of the stuff the books about
in the title again which because I'm a
big sci-fi guy dark future I mean it
just sounds like a movie that I would
have run to have seen with
Schwarzenegger in you know 1987.
um
because now so much of our information
is sorted by machines and Ai and you
just mentioned you're hanging out with a
bunch of artists right now I mean
artists are going to be hanging on by a
thread now with AI art it's crazy I
don't know if you've gone on to any of
those sites where you can basically just
put in a couple keywords and come up
with art that is to be honest incredibly
unbelievably inspiring and awesome and
it's not re you know in essence it's not
real like we're just running behind
machines almost at every front right now
so it hasn't even begun we are we are
now at the very beginning of What's
called the fourth Industrial Revolution
the fourth Industrial Revolution is
going to take the the first Industrial
Revolution began in 1760 1770 somewhere
in that so imagine what life was like in
1770 you're still crapping Outdoors
there is no such thing as a sales
manager
um there's no electricity it's
not great uh all of the changes from the
first Industrial Revolution until about
1880 where we discover electricity and
we get refrigeration and lights and
everything else to the uh to the
information age and the Space Age then
the third is the technological uh
difference in the information age really
kind of coming together
all of that from 1770 to about 2020
that whole change that kind of an impact
is going to happen in the next 10 years
and the displacement is going to be
uh Beyond understanding the problem is
we could make this we could absolutely
make this
if we had governments anywhere in the
world telling people the truth right
they're telling you about climate change
that's bullcrap and even if it isn't
bullcrap it's at least a hundred years
away okay and we could technologically
figure out ways to to
um best it in the end man will survive
but what they're not telling you is your
life is about to dramatically change to
where the uh people like Yuval Noah
Harari is uh that he's talking about
useless classes millions and millions of
people in a useless class that can't do
anything but eat
um let me pause you there for a second
because what do you make of a guy like
him he's big sort of in the wef circles
and a lot of people hate him but in an
odd way you just said he's telling us a
very dark truth that there is yeah he is
absolutely right you need to pay
attention to him but uh let's not take
any final solutions from him right uh it
doesn't you know you can be right
diagnosing the problem it doesn't make
you right uh in the solution
um and he is he is with too many people
that I mean this is very malthusian
what's happening at the wef
um you know everybody still loves George
Bernard Shaw for some reason but he's
the guy who first came up with a gas
chamber he's the guy who said there's
got to be an easier way to kill groups
of people because they're not useful to
us and they have no reason to live
um thank you thank you America's
greatest playwright
um but uh or English playwright
um
they're going down the same road we I I
believe Dave
we are seeing now
all of the things the Nazis wanted to do
we are now technologically able to do
we're able to make the Uber man we are
able to weed out the incorrect genes
we're able to round people up and
categorize them quickly I mean the only
reason why Germans were so effective in
killing Jews was because of IBM
IBM it developed the punch card system
IBM was at the concentration camps every
week working on on their computers they
knew what was going on imagine what
could be done today
that doesn't mean it has to happen it
just means I don't see a lot of our
better angels in powerful positions
so when you see the what I would
describe is as uh weakness or actual
connection to China
weakness against China or connection to
China say from the Biden Administration
and then you see what's going on in
China right now social credit 15-minute
cities uh you know people's face you do
you do something that they don't want
you to do your face is now blasted in
effect in Times Square of China all day
long so people know not to associate
with you it is quite literally an
episode of Black Mirror which I
recommend everyone watch but basically
the book is is telling us this is what
we're importing right now
oh so we're not importing it just like
we didn't import
um
Eugenics we didn't get any of that stuff
from Germany until after the war when we
did Operation Paperclip that came from
us I contend if we lose our way now our
technology will make us the the greatest
evil force ever on the face of the Earth
um and you you look at these all these
companies that have such high ESG scores
yet you're in bed with China and you're
willing to write anything for China you
you don't care about the slaves please
don't talk to me about slavery in 1850
when you are writing programs to enslave
people today in China
we are
we are now entering territories and we
talk about it in in the book dark future
um where
where it's almost these mad scientists
who are so reckless on
um AI or AGI or ASI that they
they they feel like they're I think they
feel like they're making a God and they
so want to talk and Converse and be in
the presence of omnipotence that they'll
create it and somehow or another they
think they'll be okay
we have no idea we are dealing with an
alien life
uh and
I mean I I've seen the movies this isn't
a good thing that you just run into you
know it's funny I'm listening to you and
again I'm a huge sci-fi guy the list of
sci-fi movies that have predicted all of
this whether it's the machines taking
over or the algorithms taking over or or
quite literally the last couple Alien
movies where they're trying to create
the the perfect organism and of course
the organism is going to realize guess
what I don't need you and therein lies
the rub so so yeah good have you seen
Mission Impossible yet
Glenn you are not going to believe this
I have never seen any of the Mission
Impossible movies it just it's so funny
you ask me that
wait wait wait do you like The Princess
Bride yes I love The Princess Bride
I was going to have to question our
whole friendships
inconceivable no of course something
happened you know how sometimes in life
you just get behind on one and then and
then it was mission Impossible seven and
I was like it's too late for me what can
I do it's not it's not it's really Dave
it's it's uh it's kind of like uh what's
that stupid car movie with Fast and
Furious I've never seen any of those
yeah I've seen one I think I could pick
it up at what 23 and I'd still get it
um but anyway I know they're doing
something very fast and they're pretty
pissed about it
anyway
um so the uh uh Mission Impossible talks
about uh a
a s I do should I explain the difference
yeah I think it'll help for the audience
yeah so AI is actual a-n-i it's
um artificial narrow intelligence it's
intelligent on one thing right I'll beat
you with chess every time you want to
play tiddlywinks I have no idea yeah
okay so I'm very narrow that's what we
have right now
we are natural general intelligence we
can do many things talk about many
subjects be good in many things and iffy
in other places but generally we can do
an awful lot of things we don't have
that yet this chat GPT large language
model is the first one that is taking us
into this realm and it's extraordinarily
dangerous it is miraculous and dangerous
well it's it's incredibly highly biased
which which basically we found out the
day it was sort of widely launched which
was fairly obvious to anyone that's
again C90 sci-fi movie I have said for
20 years do not fear the machine fear
the people programming the machine yeah
um so the next step is Agi that makes a
computer
as wide ranging as a man and the the the
difference between AGI and Asi
artificial super intelligence
we're not really sure and I'm not sure
it matters some people say we'll never
get there I believe we will I believe we
will shortly as soon as it's online
um uh when you know when you get to a
point and I believe this will happen in
the next two years
you will soon have an assistant that is
digital on your phone the minute it is
loaded on your phone it will know
everything about you it'll get all of
the data from everywhere
and so it will know you and it will
adapt to you as you go and this will be
unlike you know Siri is the worst yeah
you know yeah Siri where's the fire
extinguisher
I found this on the web and it's
something
stop Siri stop and scroll down stop oh
my look you gotta love it
oh my gosh so anyway
um and communication yes and
communication this is something that you
will believe is real is and it will
connect with you personally it will
serve you it will it will become your
best friend if you let it and it's a
machine and I'm telling you Dave we're
two to three years away from people
saying no
you cannot turn that off you can't
that's mine and they are real that's
that's a person to me once that happens
the whole world changes
um we are also in a society that has
become a society that is reliant on
Experts
um look where the experts have gotten us
okay the experts have gotten our
families to be our kids to be in the
highest suicide rate all of these things
they never have to account for
when a machine when A.I
is said to be infallible which will
happen very soon
who's going to argue with it how do you
argue with it how do you justify
saying no I'm not going that way
Ray Kurzweil told me well people will
just go I'm like I I probably won't Ray
I probably will want to be you know
remain natural and stupid and he said
well you would be a danger to society so
now now I've gone a useless person to a
person who is dangerous to society
because I can't keep up where do you
think that goes you know it's so
interesting because after three years of
covid and the craziness around mandates
and vaccines and everything else you
really could see it in a very clear way
how we're five years from now they've
got everybody just basically locked in
The Matrix you know one way or another
through their devices or everything
they're doing online and all that stuff
and then the few people who don't want
to join they as exactly as Jane they
have to then be considered the enemy
because what are they up to that they
don't want to be in the same system that
we're in and then we've found an awful
lot about what the way we would treat
people who don't want to do things the
way we want to do them man is you know
progressives believe that man
progressively gets better
um realists know that progress is 100
individual
if the individual progresses throughout
his lifetime that's an individual choice
and if enough of them are progressing as
individuals spiritually philosophically
then the society will progress but once
they die it's a new choice for new
little babies to start from the
beginning
um we we don't progress per se and I
think we will find out
in in record rate how uncivilized we
really are when we are
lacking energy lacking food whatever it
is we're still animals
how worried are you that even if the
machines aren't taken over and and
literally Exterminating us that just
what they could do in terms of what guys
like you and I do for a living just try
to translate the insanity into something
sensible for people that that will be so
cordoned off maybe we're there already
that you will rarely ever meet anyone on
this planet who thinks the same things
that you do or even roughly the same
things meaning that we will have all
been so atomized and manipulated through
algorithms and everything else
it will be impossible to agree on
anything
so I don't fear the machine first I
don't think the first step is it takes
over I think that's a a longer process
and I'm not sure how that happens if
that happens
um I do know that it becomes more and
more powerful and
with that power
come people
and people who are in charge of that
power
um I I think the dystopian world of even
possibly 2030 is that you don't go
anywhere Dave you and I talking to each
other each other if I am on some list
which I can guarantee you I'm on if I'm
on some list and you talk to me your
score goes down and so we can't talk to
each other unless we don't you know
unless we don't want to uh
you know fly again there's this great uh
article I just it's in the book I'm
trying to remember where I got it from I
think it's from UNESCO
um and it was written in 19 I mean sorry
in 2019 and it talks about two people
and this husband and wife and and this
is their idea of a Utopia of Tomorrow by
2030. that he takes the rapid transit he
takes the train I don't know why
it always starts with the stupid train
and uh Democrats are always like we
gotta build a new train anyway
um the so they're uh uh he goes to work
on the train and he's in work within 20
minutes however she has to ride the bus
which takes up to three hours which
means she's going to be on the bus
she'll be late for work blah blah but
she has a lower uh social credit score
and it says she recycles she does all
these things she does the right things
she raises her children right etc etc
but
he's a journalist which requires her to
talk to unsavory people with different
uh uh with different opinions which
lowers her score so she has to take the
bus for three hours every day
she's a journalist
even a journalist will be will have
points deducted if they talk to somebody
who might have a different opinion to me
sort of okay with journalists being
punished in this dystopian future I
don't know if you're fully getting me on
this one will be punished by talking to
people like us I know like us that's the
problem
well well even that that concept does it
strike you as uh strange or or why is it
that for all the warnings about all of
this in great literature and great
science fiction and biblical stories for
all the warnings of going you know
opening the Ark of the Covenant and
figuring out what the ultimate power is
we still go to it we all there's still
something within all of us otherwise you
know you'd be probably living in well
you have some locations in the middle of
nowhere but in essence we'd all dip out
if we were listening to the warnings
well I do have different places I think
you do and you should if you don't
um I'm pretty sure you told me I could
visit you on one of the dip Out
locations or you'd cordon off a little I
think I think there was a corner I think
it was a corner on the edge where the
zombies would be hitting me first if I'm
not mistaken for sure yeah I'll give you
the soon
um anyway uh uh I I think first of all
where you're where you are is where you
will be you'll have about 72 hours to
move
um you start to see a severe banking
crisis they shut down the banks they
shut things down you better be within 72
hours where you want to be or because
you may not move after that
[Music]
um
uh the um
the reason I think we don't take it
seriously is the same reason I mean I
say this
I say this in humility and also with the
knowledge it's been said forever
and I think this is why people don't
take it seriously
I think I could see The Return of Christ
in my lifetime
I think that could happen
will it I don't know I have no idea
scriptures say you should be prepared
for it am I really prepared for that no
why because it's probably not gonna
happen again it's the normalcy bias
it things like this especially in
America do not happen
but it can and it is happening and it's
not normal
would you connect some of this to uh
what people have lately been calling the
crisis of meaning that particularly
younger people are happening that are
happening having in that
they're so confused about things and
they're they're leaders and their elders
and parents generations and all of this
stuff has failed them that in a weird
way when lockdowns came around when
mandates came around they kind of wanted
it because it was just something it was
just something that was different than a
thing or when you think about the antifa
soldiers and the BLM people did they
really want to burn down their cities
and communities probably not if you
really sat them down but it was just
something and and that impulse is a very
strong impulse
never really thought of it that way
that's terrifying Dave I think you're
right
um
I I think there's going to become I mean
you can't put the kinds of people out on
the street and we're talking
30 percent by 2030. unemployment double
that of the Great Depression and it's
never coming back you can't put those
kinds of people out on the street and
expect things to go well so they better
have a good handle on you and a way to
keep you as Naval Harare says um
uh medicated and online
um so I think that there is going to be
a couple of things could happen if we're
really fortunate
uh one there could be a Great Awakening
kind of like the Jesus movement of the
70s which took the hippie movement which
was going downhill quickly into drugs
and everything else and turned it into
an uplifting kind of movement the Jesus
hippies there's a chance that life
be has become so meaningless in a way
that it did kind of in the 1960s that we
will find meaning again
um
also there is
right now we're fascinated by things we
can do that aren't real you know things
that we can you know the the filters we
use and the and the way we I mean
as somebody who has taken
thousands and thousands of pictures with
people
in the last five years maybe three for
sure
I have noticed younger people when they
take a picture of themselves or take a
picture they have especially girls they
have this pose that they go into it's
almost always the same uh and it always
happens they're not individuals anymore
they're
that's who they are in photos
and it's disturbing but I think we have
a chance of
starving for reality
and if we don't start getting hungry for
reality we're gonna be in trouble
so let's try to Veer into that positive
portion of this to to wrap up if
possible uh because I know that for as
scary as this is all we'll all get in as
dark as the future may be I know that
you will be playing through the entire
time I actually don't think that Glenn
Beck will disappear Off the Grid or
anything else and and I die before this
broadcast which again if that happens
you guys I'm telling my team they're
allowed to call me back on the grid if
some
very disturbing Glenn really you're
spending too much time up there with the
artist
just to call you and just freak you out
what what would you what would you tell
the average person that's just going
about their life they're not that
political they're not yeah
yeah so
um
don't fear you know um I'm a religious
person so I look at the scriptures for a
lot of things if you've ever read the
end of the book it's a little freaky
however
it it ends well but that's not really
happy it's like hey you're going to be
tortured for seven years and then Jesus
comes you're like okay but what about
the seven years
um I'm just telling you right now the
warnings are there to give you hope that
it doesn't last forever this won't last
forever
um this is this is uh as they say about
inflation transitory
um this too shall pass I'm pretty sure
that's in the Bible somewhere yeah yeah
and it's it's actually you are entering
a time that
no human being has ever lived right now
even if you are the poorest Among Us I
mean if you're the poorest Among Us I'm
wondering how you're watching this on
your phone but I've seen it
um even the poorest Among Us are living
at a time unlike any other time in space
or or time
and
what an honor the things that you're
going to see
the technology you know technology is
not all bad I'm a fan of Technology
um I just feel we are running into
headlong into trouble
because of arrogance
um but you're going to see miracles on
the horizon you will see uh disease much
of it wiped out possibly by 2030.
um you're going to see intelligence and
design and you worry about global
warming
wait
the the the technology when we get to
Quantum Computing we'll figure things
out in about five minutes maybe five
minutes
um Andrew's trying to get interplanetary
life going so there's all sorts and that
will most likely happen within both of
our lifetimes right the only thing to
truly be aware of
that is game changing ending
is what Stephen Hawking talked about and
I do believe it's a real possibility
the minute we start augmenting ourself
we've we fail to be human beings we fail
to be Homo sapiens
um uh and many will believe we're homo
deos that we're man Gods
the minute we start augmenting
downloading and uploading here we I mean
science fiction the Borg
will become part of the machine and the
Machine becomes part of you and that
could
and Humanity as we know it as soon as we
are only having virtual sex and we're
making our babies in tubes and
everything else which is not far away
um
are we really human
if if death goes away Ray Kurzweil told
me years ago 2006.
um he said Glenn you just have to stay
alive till 2030. and I said
okay and at the time I was doing the
math how old will I be with and uh I
said why and he said end of death by
2030.
excuse me Ray what end of death I said
we're gonna
cure all disease what do you mean by
that and he said oh no we'll just
download you we'll be able to take you
and download you into a machine and so
there won't you won't ever die you'll
still be able to be called up as a
virtual person and I said virtual person
that's not life Ray that that's that's a
pattern that's not life
um
robotic slavery right there once that
gets in the wrong hands oh my gosh oh my
gosh I just
he's still on that Quest that he
famously has been on for the last 20
years I've been like taking like he was
taking every supplement like 3 000 pills
every day and all this stuff like he he
really believes that he is going to do
what you just said right there live
forever
um and I do believe also he's doing it
to live by 2030.
um but I also believe he is on another
Quest and
I I'm not sure I mean this is an opinion
and I'm not
I'm not saying this to accuse him of
anything but I think he's trying to
recreate his father
um is when his father died he started
collecting
every bit of data he could find about
everything that he experienced and I I
do think there's something weird uh
going on almost a Frankenstein thing
with him I could be wrong and I like I
like Rey a lot I've talked to him
several times he's a re I've told him
myself
you are both the the most exciting and
Brilliant person I've ever met and also
the biggest horror show I've ever met I
just don't know which way it's going to
end
pretty sure those things come together
in the package that's that's how they're
sold
by the by the other Creator Glenn do you
have any other thoughts in case this was
your disturbing last interview
cases is my last interview
to Dave Rubin
I leave my best regards
I'd rather the acre on the thing in the
middle of nowhere with the fence and the
hole I'll send you the address
sending it to you
now love you man ciao
David bye-bye if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell